dit pas son nom
dans ce cas ligne
aujourd'hui on va dans la commune qui
accueille le groupe k centriste pour les
cordes à kabrikha vers châtellerault
bienvenue sur site de la manufacture à
châtellerault donc je vais vous
présenter un petit peu ce que nous
allons faire cet été sur le site qui est
un site que nous ouvrons aux visiteurs
alors toute l'année il est accessible de
part son jardin qui est toujours ouverte
par le skate park est toujours
accessible de par le grand atelier qui
est ouvert non grand atelier qui a trois
collections la collection d'armes
connexes de la manufacture d'armes bien
sûr une collection de vélos auto et puis
cyclomoteurs et puis également
collection roodhooft socialiste avec un
espace qui a été consacrée à roda
spécialistes et donc il est ouvert toute
l'année avec également cette année une
petite nouveauté qui nous permet de
l'ouvrir la patinoire sur toute l'année
qui est une activité roller glisse donc
c'est une activité autour du du patin à
roulettes qui est ouverte absolument
tous ceux qui ont envie de glisser y
compris en plaine et et sans avoir à
attendre que la glace soit remise sur la
patinoire et qui permet d'accueillir
petits et grands alors avec des parcours
des activités découvertes donc c'est
tous les après midi du mardi au dimanche
et puis plein d'autres activités par
exemple nous avons le bateau le jeu en
martin qui part de l'embarcadère de la
manu nous avons également le des
activités d'initiation au canoë avec une
découverte de la rivière au départ
également le canal de la manu et puis
nous avons d'autres activités comme les
descentes en rappel depuis les depuis
les cheminées wilmut qui vont avoir lieu
cet été alors ça c'est sans compter des
activités pour le coup totalement
organisé par là par la communauté
d'agglomération comme par exemple les
siestes musicales qui vont se dérouler
plusieurs fois cet été donc il y en a eu
nos produits avec nous une activité de
découverte et
méditation d'un repos pour prendre son
temps et donc apprécié à la fois le site
et en même temps profiter de l'été
tu ne
ma
où
[Musique]
donc ces activités là sont proposés avec
pour accompagner des fous trucks qui
sont là pour des glaces pour manger le
soir pour pouvoir profiter aussi
pleinement en famille du site et qui
sont qui vont et émaillée également deux
concerts ou d'autres propositions dans
nord également un cinéma de plein air
qui sera installé cet été et puis des
activités de glisse de démonstration qui
seront également proposées cet été c'est
en tous les cas une destination
incontournable on peut partir du
département de la vienne sans être passé
à la manu ça c'est sûr